uh pre-processing uh for bo for
uh saat maksat and
qbf and we have three excellent speakers
of on this topic baemin jeremias and
martina
we will talk about each of these topics
respectively
and so we for example there has been
several talks
during the workshop on encodings and in
other
areas but one of maybe
one of the most important techniques
that has been developed
in different areas and as especially in
sutton qbf but also in microsoft it
seems to be
one of the most important
progress reasons for progress is
actually pre-processing and
pre-processing has
helped to really kind of re-encode
formulas
make it much easier for them to
to solve and um
and i'm excited to hear about these
techniques for these uh
three core parts of of sod
and related areas the first speaker is
bayern kiesel
he's also a co-editor of co
author of the new pre-processing
chapter in the handbook of
satisfiability the second edition
and yeah i'm excited to hear what
what he's going to say
could you please uh share your slides
and um
take it away so you can you see my
slides hello
yes i can see it and you can also see
them in the slideshow
yep great so thank you man
so i will be talking about
pre-processing and self-solving
and as mariah mentioned i was
co-authoring a handbook article on that
during my phd i was also working on that
topic
not only pre-processing and solving but
also in
theory improving in first order logic so
yeah let's see i tried to keep this high
level to give you a few
big ideas and i hope this will get you
interested into diving deeper
not during this talk but then after
you've heard this talk
so here's the overview of what i'm going
to tell you
so i'll spend some time on the
motivation behind pre-processing why you
do it
what you should consider when you're
doing pre-processing
and then um i will just uh give a few
examples of popular pre-processing
techniques and
there are in fact so many that it would
never be possible to cover all of them
so i thought i'd just
choose a few popular ones that give you
the ideas of what's going on when you're
doing pre-processing or
to give you an idea of how such
pre-processing techniques could what
they could look like
and then i'll end with a few concluding
remarks due to
to see what we saw so
the motivation so i i
normally when i would give a talk on sat
solving or something i would start with
that slide here but i thought that one
was nice also for pre-processing
and i put the s in application here into
parentheses
and the reason is because the
application of set solving
is very important to pre-processing
because of the following
so what you normally do and i guess most
of you know this but just
just to recap you have some
problem from some problem domain like
formal verification
bioinformatics security what have you
some problem domain
and when you want to solve a problem
from such a domain using send solving
then what you do is just you take the
problem you
transform it into propositional logic so
you then get
a formal and propositional logic and
then you throw
the sat solver at it and once the sat
solver
is hopefully successful in solving the
problem you get an output and then in
many cases you decode that output
to get a solution to your original
problem
but this encoding phase into
propositional logic
is also one of the motivations behind
pre-processing because
this is often done by by a script you
would write
like when you when you're doing software
verification you might transform your
code into
propositional logic or something and
during that
transformation many things can happen
and and you could introduce lots of
redundant or unnecessary things into
your propositional formulas
that will not particularly help your
solver
and that's why you then use
pre-processing because
then you you simplify what you get
by encoding something into propositional
logic to help yourself solver a bit
so that it's easier to that it's that it
has an easier time solving your formula
and so here's what's what's happening on
a very high level you get some
formula in conjunctive normal form
normally that's the standard and set
solving
and you could use such a formula
actually as
a set of clauses and that's what i'll
also be doing over the course of this
talk
and in fact you can also view the
clauses as sets of literals
and your solver then tries to to make
this formula
true by making all the clauses true
that's what would
usually happen now with pre-processing
you
add another stage that comes before the
actual solving
and in that stage you do simplification
and actually nowadays what you also
sometimes do
is you periodically during the solving
use typical pre-processing techniques to
simplify your formula during the solving
and that's what you call in processing
and you call it in processing because
the techniques are actually
traditionally pre-processing techniques
and not classical
search techniques or solving techniques
that you would have in a typical set
solver
so as an example you would for instance
have this formula the preprocessor
considers the formula looks at it
and what it can see is that the clause
on the very right of this formula
it's a tautology this means it contains
z or not c
so this clause will always be true no
matter what assignment the solver
searches it will always be true so this
formula is
not really helpful this class is not
really helpful for the solver
so the preprocessor just throws it away
and then
when it's done it outputs the simpler
formula and then the solving can start
and now this is easy for the solver
it randomly chooses for instance to make
x true
then it's forced to make y falls and
then you get a satisfiable
and and that's basically it that's
what's happening
now the thing is um and that's really
crucial for
that so for pre-processing and set
solving that the modifications
that you apply during this
pre-processing phase they must preserve
the satisfiability status of your
formula
and what that means is simply that
whatever your solver would output before
the pre-processing
the result shouldn't change afterwards
when it comes to the decision of whether
the formula is satisfiable or
unsatisfiable
so you really don't want to change the
results because otherwise something
would be going wrong with your
pre-processing
now the thing is i said you want to
simplify a formula
and and the first question you might ask
then is what does it mean to
simplify a formula what makes the
formula really simpler
and the answer is um that generally
there is no real answer
you could think about removing something
from your formula right
and and the intuitive argument would be
that
yeah you remove something that
intuitively makes your formula smaller
so that could be simpler
and in fact many pre-processing
techniques do remove something
namely most often clauses so so that
looks promising however
if you remove the wrong things that can
have disastrous consequences
and i'll not go into the details here
but you can show
that for certain formulas when you
remove the wrong things you will
exponentially slow down your solver so
that's really disastrous
so removing is not always good but it
can be good
now um maybe you might want to add
something if removing is not always good
um cloth so typical set solvers
learn clauses during solving so they add
something so you would think
addition is good right but the thing is
especially during pre-processing it's
very hard to know uh
what to add when to add and how to add
and if you add the wrong things again
this can have bad consequences
and finally you could also think about
modifying something whatever that means
like taking parts of your formula
rewriting them
could work or could not but the
conclusion is that whatever you do
it really depends whether that will work
or not
and i actually i when you ask super
experienced people like
amin biele or barain or
what really works what should i do then
the answer i most often
also got that yeah it depends it depends
especially
on the formula at hand and on
what exactly you do when you pre-process
the formula what techniques you use how
you use them
so unfortunately there's no there's no
free lunch there's
not really a clear answer
but still we use pre-processing and
this cactus plot is what it's called
shows that it can make sense to use
pre-processing
so on the y-axis you see the run time of
the solver lingering by arming beer
at the sad competition at the sub
competition instances of 2013
and on on the x-axis you see the number
of soft
benchmarks so what that means is the
further right
the curve is the more efficient you
could say
the solver was and what we see here in
particular is on the very left
though the red solver was lingering with
all pre and in processing disabled and
on the very
right we have a version with most of the
important
pre-processing and in processing
techniques enabled
and and the main takeaway from this is
just that there is a significant
improvement
that is just caused by pre-processing
and processing
so even though it's not clear what you
should do in general
you can get a nice speed up by doing
pre-processing and in processing in
practice
so now that we that we know that it can
be good to do
pre-processing and that it can help i'll
just cover a few
simple techniques that can be effective
and that should give you an idea of
of what you could do during
pre-processing
and i'll start with the resolution rule
so
most of you will probably know the
resolution rule but just in case i
wanted to add this here to make sure
so the resolution rule is a very simple
deduction rule in propositional logic
and it says that if you have two clauses
where
one of the clauses contains a literal x
and the other
clause contains the negation of the
drill
namely not x then you can just merge the
two clauses and throw x and not
x away what you then get is in this case
c
or d a new clause that you could derive
and you can actually show
straightforward that deriving that
clause
the the new class is implied by what you
had before by the previous clauses this
is all
straightforward and what we sometimes
write
here is this we write this
circle with a cross and an x to notate
to denote the resolvent of the two
clauses upon x here
and i will use that in the in the slides
later on
so let's start with a
simple idea namely to remove classes for
which you know that they're obviously
redundant
that's something you could do for
pre-processing you just remove something
where it's very clear
that it doesn't help your solver
and one example that we have here and
that you've
already seen on the previous slide
are tautologies then the classes that
contain two complementary literals
x and not x and here we have this
example a
or b or not b so that's a tautology
because it has b or not b
and as i said before such clauses are
always true by
every assignment so they really don't
help your solver if you keep them
in there they just make your formula
larger so
you better get rid of them before you
start the solving
that's that's just a very simple idea
now there's another kind of classes
namely so-called subsumed clauses it's
also simple but very effective concept
you remove clauses if just subsumed and
what that means is
uh a clause c substance velocity if
c is a subset of b meaning all the
literals that are in c
are also contained in d and and here's
an example so a or b subsumes to class a
or b
or not c and clearly um
every assignment that satisfies c
meaning that it makes literal
in c true must also satisfy d
because it also contains the same
literals at least and therefore you can
throw away the subsumed clauses um those
are very simple techniques but
as i said they can be very efficient now
when you
implement subsumption and the removal of
some clauses then there are actually
you distinguish two kinds of removing
subsumed clauses
and the one is forward subsumption which
is straightforward
so you just go over each clause in your
formula
and then you check if one of the other
clauses
in the remaining formula subsumes it
now if that's the case then you just
remove the clause and you do this until
you've removed
all your assumed clauses now
the name already suggested if you have
forward subsumption of course you'll
also have backwards assumption
and there you you do it the other way
around
you don't start by checking if the
clause is subsumed but you check if the
clause subsumes
something so again you go over your
clauses
and then you check in the remaining
formula all clauses that are subsumed by
your particular clause
and you just remove them and that
actually works very well in practice you
can
the way you implement this there are
lots of details that you can read in our
in our article but but that's the main
idea what you can do with this
assumption
now there's a very nice special case of
subsumption and resolution namely
self-subsuming resolution
and when we look again at the resolution
rule from before
then um we could look at the special
case where
c here on the left is actually a
subclass of d
on the right then you take
below z or d usually but since c is a
subset of b what you end up is just d
and
that's when you add d
here's an example you have a or b or x
and then on the right you have a or b or
c or not x
and since a or b is a subset of a or b
or c what you end up
when you resolve these two classes what
you end up with is just a or b or c
and then when you in this case add air b
or c n b
d here then that's the same as if you
had just removed not x
from from the right clause
and that's what you're in in essence do
because since
the above clause is then subsumed by the
clause you derived you could throw away
the above clause
and and that's basically what
self-subsuming resolution then does
so you have two clauses c or
x and not x or d such that c subsumes t
and then self self-subsuming resolution
just removes not x from not x or d so
you remove literals from
classes and that makes the clauses
stronger give you more detective
power moshe has a question
sure so for many years the con
the conventional wisdom was that
subsumption is too expensive it's not
worth it
uh what is the what is the current
wisdom
that's that's good uh because um when we
wrote our
pre-processing article then i mean
pierre was really the main man when it
comes to subsumption
so i think self-subsuming resolution
when you do the special case this works
well
but i think really um that amin would be
the one who should answer this question
because he could do it way better
than i could if he's still here
is armin are you there yeah sure um yeah
already back then when we wrote this
paper uh actually i
sure marcus silva came to me and said
this is impossible you can't do
a subsumption all the time but even back
like 15 years back
it was clear there are a couple of
implementation tricks that you can do it
and uh yeah so you can play with both
forward and backward subsumption
you need to add some limits so like
typically limits are that you're not
doing this if you have a locals more
than 100 times but if you do that you
can do this
always until completion for 10 million
100 million variables no problem
yeah yeah please continue
yeah so that's um substantial
subsumption and self-subsuming
resolution
now we'll come to something where where
subsumption can help you speed it up
and that's called variable elimination
and actually variable elimination
can be considered the most effective
pre-processing technique
in all of that solving so if
if pre-processing techniques were
basketballers then variable elimination
would be michael jordan you could say
and and here's what it does so the
simple idea is just
you look at your formula you pick a
variable
and then you just add all possible
non-tautology
tautological results upon this variable
and once you've done this
you remove the original classes that
contain the variable
and what you end up with is a formula
that doesn't contain
the variable anymore
and that's the basic idea more formally
to define what it does you can define a
resolution rule for sets of clauses so
here i denote
f resolved with g where f and g
are sets of clauses as the set of all
resolvents
with clauses from f and clauses of
b upon x
and what you require is that the
resolvent is not the tautology so all
non-topological resolvents upon
variable x you could view this a bit
like
a join in relational algebra if you want
not really but but the idea is
similar now if you're given the literal
x you define
the formula f x as basically
the set of all classes of f that contain
x
and once you have this you can define
variable elimination as follows so given
the cnf formula f
variable elimination also called dp
resolution
removes the variable x by replacing the
sets f
x and f not x with the set f x
resolution joined with f not x
and actually if you do this
until fixed point so you pick the
variable you eliminate it you pick the
next variable you eliminate it and you
go on
until fixed point then what you get is
either the empty formula which clearly
is satisfiable or the empty clause which
clearly is unsatisfiable
and and so you have a foolproof
procedure for propositional logic as
introduced originally by davis and
platinum very popular
[Music]
basically the first the first nice uh
proof system approved procedure that
current sat solving is now
based on but it's just all with
way more details nowadays
and here's an example for instance if um
on the top you have these three classes
that contain x that's your
f x and left you have the clauses that
contain not x
and then you consider all resolvents
like here you have not x or a result
with x or c then you get a or c
and here if you do not x i think you get
it
and then the only thing that remains is
that if you look at the two clauses on
the top right here
you can remove them because um this here
contains a or not a and this here
contains b are not b so they're
tautologies
but still now when you look at the
result of of this resolution then you
will notice something
namely that here we started out with six
classes
and we ended up with seven classes and
that's not too bad
but in general what you can get when you
do this is you can get exponential
growth
and that will really blow up everything
your class set
which is bad the question is what can
you do
and what you can do is you when you do
variable elimination
you do it just on on variables where
there is no blow up where the resulting
set of formula
of classes is no larger than what you
had
before now now that's what you would do
and this avoids the exponential growth
that you have when you deny
variable elimination now
like in
austria for instance in politics it's
it's very common that
we like to come up with many rules we
specify them in lots of detail
and it's all fleshed out nicely but then
when push comes to shove in the end you
don't stick to the rules you just do
something a little different and it's
all fine and everybody agrees that
that's okay
and that's also what happens here in
practice because
um you don't really stick to the rule
nowadays
you say you loosen it a bit and what you
do is you say okay
we can increase this bound incrementally
as long as the size
increase that we get from eliminating
variables is moderate
whatever that means
and as i said this is arguably the most
important pre-processing techniques
in when it was first introduced into the
sun competition atlanta
together with other things to the
largest improvement of solver
performance
that have been witnessed until then and
i think until
today and what's nice is that it's
particularly effective if you combine it
with subsumption
so you you eliminate the variable you
add the resolvence and then you
perform subsumption you remove subsumed
classes for instance
or you combine it with blocked class
elimination
which is another type of class
elimination technique for pre-processing
and that one i will get to next so
what do you mean there's one question in
the in the chat
regarding so if you if you eliminate a
variable with boundless variable
elimination
how do you get the solution where the
the variable that is eliminated
is for so solution for the original
formula
so um
that is a very good question normally
what you do is when you go
up your resolution tree you can
reconstruct
the the assignment from looking at your
assignment tree and seeing
you always know it must make one of the
clauses
um true if the
so your resolved clauses are true
this means that one of the two clauses
from which it was resolved
must be true by the same assignment and
then you can just pick one of the
literals one face of the literal and
make it true
because one of so one of the clauses
must be true anyhow and the other one
will be true
if you make your literal true does that
make sense
or is that see out is it clear
now he's uh he's an entertainer so he
cannot answer
um yeah maybe maybe we can get back to
that afterwards
sounds good
so um do you have the time how long is
[Music]
yeah so so uh it's now uh
11 of noon but here
but so you have
[Music]
but you have a little bit more time just
maybe let's see if i'll then skip hyper
binary resolution we'll see
but let's move on so block losses
so we saw that you can remove classes
that are redundant meaning that they
don't really affect what your solver
does
but for these clauses actually what we
saw like for tautologies
um what you get is if an assignment
makes a formula true then that
assignment also makes your formula true
once
after you removed the clause and the
same is true for
subsumed clauses now with blocked
clauses
you loosen this requirement a bit and
say i don't exactly
need um the formulas
before removing the clause and after
removing the clause to be satisfied by
the same assignments
i'm fine if i just know that
the result is satisfiable
or if the original formula is
satisfiable then the result
is also satisfiable or if they're both
unsatisfiable so
you really just care about the
satisfiability status but not about the
actual assignments that you're
considering
and and you say a class is blocked if
all resolvents
of that clause upon one of its literals
are tautologies
and here's an example so we have the
class c
and now we pick one of its literals in
this case b
and we consider all resolvents upon this
literal in this case we can resolve
with the two clauses in the middle
because they don't because they contain
not b
we can ignore the other two clauses
because they don't
contain not b and then uh we look at the
actual resolvence and what we get
is that um one resolvent would be x or y
or not y
and the other one would be x or y or not
x and in both we have complementary
literals
and that means that the clause is
blocked there are tautologies so the
class is blocked
all resolvents are tautologies more
formally
as defined by kuhlman originally when he
introduced the concept of a blocked
clause
the same clause is blocked by literal b
and formula f if for every clause d that
contains not b
the resolvent of c and d upon p b is a
tautology
now um you can prove
that if c is blocked in f then f and f
and not
c are equally satisfiable and that proof
is actually not too hard
but i'll i'll i'll not give it here but
it's it's pretty much straightforward
and now in pre-processing when you do
block loss elimination
you just start with a formula f and you
remove block clauses until no class is
blocked in f
which is not 100 percent true because
sometimes you might not want to run
block clause elimination until fixed
point but just
until some time limit or something but
but you can run it until fixed point
and that's how i define it here and
and here's an example this formula a or
b and a
and so on here if you take a closer look
you you could see that um
the the middle class is blocked so you
could remove it and
and the same holds true for the last
class
and and once you remove one of them the
first class also becomes blocked and
then you can also remove it
and what happens here is that in this
case
block clause elimination could remove
all of your clauses so you can see that
by removing certain clauses new clauses
can become blocked and so on and then
you can go on removing classes and this
can
lead to the removal of many classes
and what you can actually show is that
block loss elimination
if you do it until fixed point is
confluent
meaning that the order of eliminations
does not affect the outcome so you start
you just check non-deterministically you
pick a
blocked class you remove it then you
pick the next block clause new classes
might become blocked
you remove them too but how ever you do
it in
no matter what order you will always get
the same result and actually that the
same is true also for block loss
elimination in first order logic
so not only in propositional logic
the the cool thing about block class
elimination is that it can do
many nice things like when you convert
the formula that is not in conjunctive
normal form
into into conjunctive normal form then
you could use detecting encoding
which is usually used in practice
and but there's also to place the green
bomb encoding which is uh basically a
subset of
tectin and what you can show is that
actually if you apply block class
elimination
to the satin encoding you can get the
blasted green bomb encoding
and likewise you can do a few circuit
simplification techniques that are
that are simulated if you do them on a
cnf
like if you know them pure literal
elimination or a cone of influence
and here is an example where you do
circuit simplification i'm not going
into the details here
but this would be the encoding of the
circuit and you can if you
if you take the time to check it you can
see that by block loss elimination you
can actually
start removing these classes and then
those and so on
and you basically remove everything here
now one more thing i said that you
that it's not always the same
assignments that satisfy the formula
before and after pre-processing
so there's a technique for solution
reconstruction
and this is very straightforward um
actually
linear as you can see at least
this this while over the stack of
eliminated block classes you
so while you do block loss elimination
you save your block losses together with
the literal
that blocked them and and then you take
your formula
and start with an assignment that
satisfies your formula that would be
your resulting formula of pre-processing
and then you just go you you pop
literals from your stack you start with
the first one
then you check your assignment if it
falsifies your clause
if it doesn't falsify falsify your
clause then you're fine your assignment
satisfies
the formula even if you add c and if not
you just make the blocking literal true
and that's it
and and this it's guaranteed that this
satisfies the outcome and you do this
continuously until you're done
with all your clauses and then you
return the assignment and you're fine
and why this works this basically based
on this proof that i mentioned white
block clauses are
redundant and can be removed
so um do we have more time for hyper
binary resolution or should i jump
straight to the concluding
i think you better go to the concluding
ring yeah
all right so um
as a conclusion i mentioned that there
are many many techniques and that
here i just considered a few of them but
there are really many
like we saw subsumption variable
elimination block loss elimination
unfortunately we didn't see hyper binary
resolution but there are also others
like bonded variable addition
equivalent literal substitution what
have you and the list is growing there
will there will come more and more
pre-processing techniques and as i
mentioned in the beginning
unfortunately it's not always clear what
does or does not work
in practice and that really depends a
lot on formula 10 so what that means is
that if you have
a certain formula and your subsolver
can't solve it
you might want to play around with using
pre-processing techniques and i i think
marine is a great example for this
when he solved the pythagorean triples
problem
because he had this nice mathematical
problem that nobody could solve
and he of course with his experience saw
that many of the clauses that he got
when he encoded
the problem into propositional logic
were blocked losses
so he could eliminate many of them with
block clause elimination
and it worked so so you might really
want to consider using some of the
techniques
because maybe if they don't work well in
general they might work on the formulas
you you're dealing with in your
application domain be it
software verification or whatever
now i've only given you a very high
level talk as i mentioned in the
beginning but
if you want to get more details then i
recommend you have a look
at the handbook of satisfiability
because uh
the second edition was published just
recently and it now contains
in contrast to the first edition also an
article on pre-processing
that contains many many details on the
things i mentioned during the talk
and also many more techniques and
backgrounds
and references so with that
thank you and if you have any questions
glad to answer them
[Music]
um many thanks for this very nice talk
of miami
um yes um i want to just repeat it
who has questions
so maybe you can kind of uh start with
maybe
answering a bit more what ziat mentioned
regarding variable
elimination because how kind of you can
can you use this algorithm for block
clauses also for
uh for variable elimination
okay how how you can use the block
clause
class
[Music]
you mean the solution reconstruction
yeah so so you eliminate variables one
by one right
yeah and then when you add them again
um you know um that it that
all the causes that you resolved from
um must have a satisfying assignment if
the resulting
resolvence can be satisfied but those
clauses
they contain either the literal in one
face
or in another phase and then you just
look
at when you add the variables again what
phase do you need to make true
to make the original clauses true and
then you pick the literal in one of
these faces
and you add it and you do this
continuously for
for your whole formula and then you will
end up with a satisfying assignment of
your original formula
and i think um couldn't you even show
that it doesn't even matter in many
cases and
just add whatever face you want
you would need to look into the details
again i
i don't think so i think if as soon as
clauses form a definition right there's
only one way you can you can utilize it
um maybe you can tell a little bit more
about kind of your own pre-processing
work and also for example do you see for
example that you can have a
useful kind of pr um
pre-processing in the future do you see
something like this happening for
example
yeah yeah so so what i was working on
mainly was on the one hand to come up
with generalizations of blocked clauses
so we saw that for uh that was one thing
when you look at the plot clause for
instance you say it's a clause where all
resolvents on one literal
are tautologies so
um together with amin and mattina
and then later also with you we we look
if there if you can do something more
general not
only requiring that there's a literal
when you resolve away
you you get tautologies but for instance
something
a set of literals in your class
that when you do some kind of resolution
generalized to sets
you still get tautologies and you could
take this idea further and so on but
what you get is clauses
um types of clauses that include plot
clauses but there are even more clauses
of which you know that they're redundant
now first we thought might be a good
idea to remove them but
it later turned out that adding them
makes more sense
and what you can show is that by adding
these more
general clauses those generalizations of
block clauses
you can define proof systems where you
say okay
here is my proof system i get a formula
in cnf and i can add new clauses
if they're for instance blocked clauses
or more general types of redundant
clauses
and what you then get with these more
general types of processes that you can
often get very short proofs of popular
formulas
for which you don't have short proofs
with resolution for instance
and for which you might have short
proofs in systems like extended
resolution
but in those systems you introduce new
variables
with definitions as you mentioned before
but
with those strong improved systems you
can actually avoid
adding new variables and still get very
nice short proofs
based on adding what's basically
redundant class
yeah cool uh so there's also one
question on youtube
um and that's what
so what is the what shot solving is
happening at sap
what's that solving is happening at sap
well sub solving itself not
much but there's currently a team in
newport beach
i'm not sure how much i'm allowed to
tell you here but
but you know that sap has this
programming language called abba which
is
very sap related and what happens a lot
in practice is people have old code and
up
and they don't want to touch it because
this is legacy code nobody wants to
touch it because if you change a thing
here or there
might might ruin everything right so you
have this legacy code that nobody dares
to touch
but colleagues in newport beach are now
looking into
using smt solvers to prove program
equivalence
of above programs in certain situations
so that if someone touches the code
if they can guarantee with the s t
somewhere that what they produced is
equivalent to the original program
then then the simplification of the code
was safe
now everybody knows that in general
program equivalence is undecidable i
don't have to tell you this
but but in certain special cases and
with restricted syntax
um this can actually work that that's
one thing that's currently done with sap
okay cool to hear that more and more
companies are using this technology
right
uh emerald has a question uh would you
like to
do this directly amir
sure so i'm referring to like
i guess uh some slide in the first 10
slides
you mentioned like when talking about
pre-processing yeah
around here so removing the wrong things
can have disastrous consequences is it
like
an observed uh disastrous consequence or
is it
like a prove uh disastrous consequence
so so that's a good question what i'm
here like what i imagine
when i when i say that removing the
wrong things can have disastrous
consequences
um in particular is something that's
kind of a proof but it's not really
proof because it's a simple observation
so if you're familiar with proof theory
with proof complexity and propositional
logic for instance
you know that the pigeonhole formulas
this is well it's a well-known kind of
formulas and propositional logic
they only have resolution proofs of
exponential size
depending on some parameter n
now most normal sat solvers are
based on resolution and that means that
these formulas
your set solver will take exponential
time on the formulas
now what you can do however is you can
add certain definition classes to the
kitchenaid formulas
and suddenly everything will be way
easier for your sat solver
and you get an exponential speed up and
now what
imagine it the other way around now
think you uh think about
the following you have added these nice
definition classes now your solver
should in theory be fast but now your
pre-processing technique comes
and actually blocked glass elimination
that i mentioned
removes definitions so it would remove
your nice
definitions and what you end up with is
then the formula that takes
exponentially longer
so that's one example
um are there any other questions
in that case bayman i would like to
thank you again for this very nice talk
thank you and uh could you then stop
sharing
and uh jeremias
could you start sharing